today we're going to be speaking with
tim miller who's a writer and political
consultant the author of why we did it a
travelogue from the republican road to
hell and his show is also available on
snapchat and is called not my party tim
great having you on i really appreciate
it david i've seen you on the uh the
youtube's been feeding you to me so oh
that's good that's chocolate
usually right-wing stuff is fed to
left-wingers but i like to see the
opposite happening a little bit so i
mean okay just to kind of um
like orient our audience sure you are
not on the trump train for lack of a
better term but i think it would be
interesting to hear about
when did you start to think that the
republican party was going in a
direction that you didn't like that
didn't make sense to your values yeah
well this is uh you're hitting at the
regrets part of the book the why we did
it we is an important word there because
i'm included in we even though i i
bailed on trump uh at the minute he went
down that escalator bailed on on the
idea that i would support him but as i
look back on it one of my first jobs in
politics is i was the iowa spokesperson
for john mccain during the 2008 primary
uh and so uh i was obviously the lead
off kickoff the caucus states was a very
important kind of role i was excited
about the role and
uh
the types of people that were showing up
to the john mccain uh town halls that we
would have and the kind of questions
that he was getting over and over about
their concerns about the invasion at the
southern border and you know globalists
and the nafta super highway this was a
conspiracy theory back at the time that
never came to pass i don't know if you
noticed we never did get that nafta
super highway but right these folks
would come
and and i started to get get a sense
that oh man like maybe the like the
people that make up this party you know
have a set of values that are separate
from mine then obviously mccain goes on
to take pick sarah palin palin uh the
rallies the palin rallies were were very
much a proto
example of these trump rallies right of
of people shouting about barack hussein
obama and being a muslim
and so you know i i kind of rationalize
that and justified it because i still
like john mccain and still
believed in his political program which
was like quite different than donald
trump's political program and
i was ambitious you know and wanted to
continue to be successful in my career
and so i think that using a few
different rationalizations i kind of
blocked out the fact that i in
retrospect i really saw this all coming
in 2007. yeah and what's interesting
about that is there's this viral moment
where at some event i don't remember
where it was this woman asks john mccain
uh you know or not even really ask just
sort of says like i think obama's a
muslim and mccain says no he's not he's
an american and he's just someone with
whom i have political differences so
that was sort of the type of signal
you're talking about here for sure and
and it helps me justify staying along
with john mccain right and there is a
like sometimes people on the left want
to be like the party was always
corrupted it was always racist was
always horrible and it's like well there
were elements that that is true right
but but also leadership does matter and
having somebody at the top of the ticket
who would say no ma'am that is not true
having someone at the top of the ticket
during mccain's concession speech he was
graceful he was getting booed when he
said we all need to unite behind our new
president and give us our support he
gets booed by the crowd so you can see
this tension right between somebody
who's trying to be a leader and a
statesman who has some conservative
values
and a reactionary political base that's
looking for someone to feed their
grievance
the base got what they wanted uh you
know about eight years later so
what
were the issues
that to you are the important political
issues that that make you or made you a
republican like is it is it taxation is
it regulation what what is it
yeah i hate to be a cliche but i was
always one of these people who was kind
of socially liberal um uh you know
though i
the word pro-life is is getting uh
mangled these days what does that mean
like uh you know i believe there should
be some some restrictions on abortion i
don't know my abortion position might be
closer to bill clinton in 1992 than the
current pro-life position but but any
but besides that i was pretty socially
liberal and yeah i i think the
government uh a lot of times gets in the
way of uh of economic growth of
prosperity in our society i'm obviously
a capitalist i think that america is a
force uh can play a force for good in
the world um you know i think this is
frankly more of a joe biden point of
view these days than it is at donald
trump point of view but you know i i do
believe in an american you know power
and influence over
overseas uh and you know i i believe
that america was a shining city on the
hill where we should be welcoming people
from throughout the world and and that
they can have their opportunity to take
the blessings of the of the country
right like for that was like a core
republican view as i was growing up
right in the 80s and 90s right
reagan and bush were very liberal on
immigration and you know they spoke to
american greatness and believing in the
american experiment a lot of times i
look at the left and say oh they're down
talking america you know they want to
change what is good about the country
and so that is kind of what had me
falling on the republican side despite
the fact that i obviously had
disagreements with parts of the nativist
wing of the party on immigration i'm gay
we haven't talked about that obviously
on gay marriage and those issues i
disagreed and i came to disagree with
the more extreme
you know views even on economic issues
that were you know uh that the tea party
you know and the you know shutting down
the government you know we can never
raise taxes on on anyone making over 400
000 right some of these extreme economic
views i i've sort of come around to the
center on
so
it seems clear that now there are lots
of folks who are
sincerely trump supporters and then
there are some folks on the republican
side who are overtly anti-trump and then
there's sort of like the suspicion which
i think we've we've learned is is true
that there are people who are kind of
publicly trump supporters but really
privately they are not can you talk
about like early when it became clear
trump was becoming the nominee what was
your experience of those kind of three
groups and maybe that the third one is
really the most interesting the ones who
publicly are still defending him but but
pr pub privately rather did not like him
yeah the third group i think is the most
interesting group and that's who the
book focuses on right i i don't i i sort
of hated all the never trumper books
that like wanted to make us seem like
the heroes like to me i don't i didn't
think we were heroes trump was
manifestly unfit and corrupt and
dangerous and racist and it's like i i
did the obvious thing in my opinion
the genuine trump supporters i think
there's an interesting book to be
written about them right i think this is
a real streak within our country right
now i saw that up close we talked about
it these iowa events people who are
genuinely nativists uh genuine
protectionist
wanted to change kind of this uh the way
that uh you know the post-world war ii
kind of american you know set up setup
of america's role in the world um the
third group though is one who agrees
with me on everything but but basically
wanted to continue on with their
political career or maybe they don't
agree with me on everything right i
think that the liz cheney at least
stefanik is a good example of this right
liz cheney is far more conservative than
me
on social issues on foreign policy even
at least ifanak and i work together
she's one of the chapters in the book
she and i were rhino squish moderate
republicans right she believes climate
change is real she believes in gay
marriage she you know wanted a liberal
immigration policy uh but you know she
also believed in lower taxes and a
strong america overseas well elise
stefanik is now the one who is rising
within the party and not liz cheney
because she is willing to go along with
the cult and go write the lies unless
cheney wants them so so in that third
group you know what shocked me it did
not shock me that trump took over the
party i like i said in 07 i got a hint
that something like this could happen um
it did not what shocked me was just to a
person how almost everyone i had worked
with ended up going along with it and i
would have these dinners and these
breakfasts these tortured drinks where
people would explain oh you know all
their rationales
and so what i tried to explore in the
book is
all these different rationales the ones
that are ridiculous the ones that are
mockable the ones that are kind of in
the ballpark of defensible um uh
and try to adjudicate
how it was that these people i think who
are the central
villains essentially of the book and of
our time um
came to decide to do what they did
because trump couldn't have gotten power
just with the true believers right like
there aren't enough of them he had to
win over that third group right
who strikes you as a sort of uh faking
it type republican right now of the
people that are kind of in the public
eye defending trump
um well most of them uh kevin mccarthy
and elise obvi i i guess i just talked
about elise but kevin kevin mccarthy uh
you know i saw i i write in the book
about lindsey graham you know lindsey
graham and i he supported jed i was
jeb's communications director we spent a
lot of time together um you know he
would call me all the time ranting about
donald trump how much he hated him like
one night i couldn't get away from him
because he was drinking all the
chardonnay ranting about how trump is a
racist and a bigot so i is he faking it
now or i i don't know if faking it is
right word i think that he's come around
to believing that the thing that he
cares about the most is access to power
and and that he can deal with trump's
flaws in exchange for what he thinks
he's getting which is influence access
to powers i don't know if he's faking it
so much as he's just his calculation has
changed uh but i think most of the
political strategists in the
uh which is which is what i talk about
are you know at some level
you know not
it would be if they all let's just put
it this way
pretty much everybody in the
establishment wing and the republican
party if they could snap their fingers
and have a magic genie appear and say
donald trump is just going to disappear
from the face of the planet and ron
desantis is going to take over the party
they all would snap their fingers in a
second oh well so let me talk about that
yeah that was going to be my next
question in terms of like what's the
path out of this because the interesting
thing about you mentioning desantis is
when i think about john mccain and mitt
romney um desantis seems way more like
trump than like any of them so i'm kind
of interested in
the path out of this trumpist nightmare
on the republican side does it have to
be someone like desantis who i almost
see as like a slightly less incompetent
version of trump but close to his
dangerous is that just by necessity what
it has to be or is there a way to get
back to someone like a mitt romney who
seems so comparatively benign right now
yeah there's no path back to the benign
i mean at least in the short term um
here's the thing the ant
donald trump gave these the people this
is a bottom-up problem not a top-down
problem and the book is about people's
moral
sacrifices right and how they went along
with somebody that they that was
clownishly corrupt right yeah um just
for their own power so so that part you
know
they're complicit they but but what is
the core issue here is that is that what
voters want is someone that's going to
channel their grievance and their rage
and their hate for the left for elites
for the media for you know whatever uh
people who are expressing their gender
identity in different ways right like
their hatred for whoever that is they
want someone to channel that that's what
they care about not policies right this
is the difference between the dem base
and the republican base like there may
be some people on the dem base who have
extreme views but they have actual
policies that they want to see enacted
the republican base just want somebody
to channel their grievance and so okay
if that's what these voters want they're
never gonna they're not turning back to
anyone like mitt romney after donald
trump gave him what they could have like
for a while they're like oh i'll hold my
nose for john mccain because this is the
best we can do we need somebody like
this to win now they have come to
realize no we can win with someone that
that shares our
cruelty and our hatred and so why would
we go back to mitt romney right like
they never would and so no i i think
that there's a possible chance for
somebody who is a like a boris johnson
type i wouldn't call that benign i think
that is our best hope right somebody who
can fake the grievance stuff you know
and throw people a little bit of red
meat you know with some cultural
um
resentments which boris was good at but
but like on the policy side of things is
like was basically you know kind of like
a center-right nationalist you know not
not exactly the kind of person i would
want not like a classically liberal
conservative but i i think it's possible
that someone like that could appear but
no the desantis mold is is the way the
party's going for sure or or maybe even
worse honestly maybe even tucker or
something to that effect well
in looking at some of these recent trump
rallies and cpac
what gets the most applause
is the overtly homophobic and
transphobic stuff like in watching cpac
the crowd was kind of dead
until
ted cruz ridiculed pronouns and i don't
remember who it was talked about trans
women in sports like the the applause
lines were the homophobic transphobic
applause lines trump now tells the story
about the weightlifting
and the swimmer you know it's the it's
these every single rally it's the same
stories is that surprising to see that
kind of resurface
i wouldn't say so it's disappointing
because
look we all play these games like in my
head
i felt like the gay rights
march was going forward and we those of
us on the pro gay rights side were
winning and so
you know i that it wasn't you know by
the time i really came into politics
like the writing was on the wall right
like the march for to progress was
marching forward and thank thank you to
all the people that did that fight
before we got there but but
i should have see we should have known
that there would be backsliding right
the types these people their hatreds
their cruelty they didn't go away you
know a lot of times the republicans get
caricatured as like being so stupid that
they don't know what they're doing
they're they're strategic they're
tactical if you'd listen to focus groups
or republican voters that they didn't
change their mind on gay marriage
they're just like well this is a loser
for us right like it's not worth
fighting it right now right it's a
political loser we're going to go win on
other issues that's why they moved on to
the trans stuff right
uh now with the with what desantis is
doing in the schools don't say gay the
pronouns the tran the transports they're
emboldened again they're like wait a
minute no this can be a winner we can
bring the our our um
you know we can otherize them and attack
them and that can be a political winner
for us again so we're going to do that
and so i so you know while i think the
good natured side of me was hoping that
this stuff was passed i don't think it
should be surprising because it's not
like these people died they're all still
here all the people that still did you
know that were for anti-gay marriage
initiatives in 2004 uh most of them are
still around right so um uh you know
it's not it's not as if all of their
views changed they just made a political
calculation so the snapchat show not my
party i don't even understand snapchat
like i'm on tick tock tick tock i get
and we're doing well on tech talk
my sister is on snapchat she says it's
it's really like the hub for people who
are a little bit younger than me
yeah how did this develop
well basically so snapchat had these
shows and it's mostly for 13 to 24 year
olds right who are on it essentially and
and they had like ben shapiro you know
and they had like super left stuff maybe
like you're you're not on there but some
of your competitors out there in the
left space right the actual socialists
not like
yeah the actual social so the snapchat
folks came to me like we need like
somebody in the middle like we besides
charlie kirk and you know aoc right like
we need to serve this audience because
there are a lot of teens out there still
kind of working their way through their
political identity and so i try to offer
a show once a week post on thursdays on
snapchat it's just four minutes it's fun
it's fast and it's like hey here's a
look at the news and here's a look at
what's happening in politics we talked
about the student loan thing and and i
don't i hate to say balanced because i'm
not trying to do this fake centrist oh
on the one hand on the other hand thing
but it's like we're heterodox right like
i don't every once in a while i still
agree with the republican on something
right but we're i'm not magga you know
i'm not going to tell you exactly what
you want to hear every week and so i
hear a lot from kids in college who
appreciate the show because they're like
man on campus everyone is either
you know in the k f in the k hive or a
social justice warrior or a mega and i
don't fit that and i think that a lot of
people feel that way and so they're
trying to navigate through their views
and so i think that the fact that i've
been
cast out from the republican party it
gives me a chance to have the freedom to
just kind of tell people and give people
an honest look at what's happening well
uh i got to get on that snapchat i've
got to figure out what's going on on
there your show would do well i should
really sample some some clips on there
it's an interesting idea actually um
tim's show is not my party on snapchat
the book is why we did it a travelogue
from the republican road to hell
we've been speaking with tim miller tim
thank you so much david thanks brother